[Music]  now that the long road to brexit has  officially begun MEP s will set out  their conditions for approving the  separation deal between the EU and the  UK after leaky silicone breast implants  and faulty hip replacements it's time to  take a closer look at medical devices  mep s will vote on how to make  procedures safer the car emissions  scandal has revealed that the european  monitoring agency is direly needed and  tests on the road should trump those  made in labs parliaments will set out  its recommendations Ukrainians can plan  for summer holidays in Europe mep s will  vote on granting them visa-free access  to the EU and how much should phone  companies charge each other abroad  Parliament's will seal the deal and end  roaming charges for consumers this  summer